la alta autoridad para la salud en a
francia recomiendo una sola dosis para
las personas que ya superaron el hobbit
19 una dosis que además ellos piden sea
suministrada unos tres meses a seis
meses idealmente después de superada la
infección esto se debe a que estas
personas desarrollaron una memoria
inmunológica y solamente necesitan una
dosis a manera de refuerzo además esto
podría ayudarles también a que los
efectos secundarios de la vacuna sean
menos fuertes pues en este grupo de
personas según estudios que se han
realizado en francia los efectos
secundarios como por ejemplo dolores
musculares y fatiga son mucho más
intensos que en el resto de las personas
vacunadas las que no han pasado por el
comida 19 otro de los beneficios de esta
recomendación pues sería simplemente
tener más vacunas economizar el número
de vacunas sobre todo cuando hay un
rezago en el suministro de dosis a nivel
europeo recordemos además que en europa
las tres vacunas ya que fueron aprobadas
necesitan de dos dosis
ahora hay que esperar que sea el
gobierno nacional el que dé el aval de
si sigue o no las recomendaciones de la
autoridad sanitaria y por último pues ya
a nivel europeo también se está
estudiando la aprobación de la vacuna de
johnson y johnson que en este caso
solamente requiere de una sola dosis